because when I'm in the yearning when
I'm in the desire that's when all my
stuff comes out and I become brilliant
and I have to finish my show I have to
get that thing performed you know I've
been working on that for long do you
think how passionate by the way are you
about your career now could you just
finish totally I'm totally passionate
about it yet that's why I'm doing it I
make it and mounting this show that's
unbelievable with video and and and and
soundtrack I've just when is this gonna
happen well that's the thing I just I
either got to get somebody to break my
heart so I can finish it or more
material yeah but also this is the thing
what I find myself doing is I'm I'm
looking to be in that stage of need and
and I find that I'm attracted to you
know things that will put me in that
state of need because it seems to be the
only way that I can create something as
if I want something or somebody that
doesn't want me do you want to stop the
cycle no that's my point I can you over
so you're telling me it gets me going so
you're not really sad those things don't
work so this is all just come on I'm not
kidding do you think every great thing
came from you your heartbreak or somehow
you get a yearning yearning not an
Harpeth yearning desire but was ire
desire desire do you want that sexual
did I just desire desire desire that's
what gets me to be in that state of
desire so you really don't need someone
you really deep down no I do I need a
guy who make me to make you feel the
desire so you could use him for when he
dumps you
how could he really dump you if you want
him to dump you because I pick someone
who will never get there in the first
place I think deep down you're full of
[ __ ] I think deep down there's something
that you really do want something
meaningful and long I guess you haven't
hurt you haven't heard but also you have
had great sex you've had a great life
you've had all these great things so
maybe you just want to focus on your
career I don't know you tell me that was
awfully demanding Michael God I said you
liked it
you're being in charge of me a big enjoy
being in charge
ooh yes I want yes I want to keep doing
what I'm doing with my eyes on the prize
of full expression of what it's meant to
be alive on my path it's good stuff that
I must share that I want to share